The social readjustment rating scale looked at different types of life events
that could be considered stressers. Each event could be scored on a range from
10 to 100, depending on how stressful it was. At the top of the list, we see
death of a spouse being the most stressful life event. At the bottom of the
list with a rating of 11, we see really minor legal violations. And with a
rating of 12 there's Christmas. So. here we see that holidays are even on the
scale of stressful life events, although they aren't necessarily bad things.
So, this shows that even positive things can be stressful. Have you ever the
phrase, I need a vacation from my vacation? That's just another example to show
that stress is not just associated with uncomfortable or unwanted things like
divorce or death of a spouse. It's also associated what what we consider to be
positive or fun events, like vacations or holidays.